jojo siwa it's time to find a
mirrorball-themed bow because you've got
a groundbreaking gig on the horizon
all right that's me that's me
on thursday abc announced that the 18
year old entertainer is heading to the
ballroom joining the cast of season 30
of dancing with the stars but the
biggest news jojo will also be making
history this season
thank you thank you thank you for the
first time ever dancing with the stars
will feature a same-sex dance pair and
jojo will be partnered with a female pro
dancer
speaking at abc's television critics
association virtual press tour jojo said
quote there are a lot of barriers we're
going to have to break through who leads
how do you dress what shoes do you wear
it's all something that i'm looking
forward to it's going to be tricky but
it's going to give so much to people out
there
jojo's casting comes just months after
she publicly came out about her
sexuality and revealed she's in a
relationship with girlfriend kylie prue
who she totally gushed over during a
recent chat with e.t
we just like to be together you know we
don't we don't forget what we do as long
as we're having fun the remaining cast
members will be revealed on september
8th and jojo is gonna have to sit tight
a little longer to find out who her
dance partner is but she did say she'd
love to work with lindsey arnold jenna
johnson or brit stewart
season 30 of dancing with the stars
premieres september 20th on abc
are you excited to meet abby lee
[Music]
the casting is also full circle for jojo
seeing as she first came into our lives
on another hit reality series
jojo
those are big shoes to film i can do it
jojo competed on abby's ultimate dance
competition and starred on two seasons
of dance moms
at the helm of it abby lee miller who
has praised her former dance student
how proud of you of joe jones i'm very
proud i'm very proud i i don't know if
she's just a marketing genius and we
don't know this yet
uh i'm proud of her i'm proud of
everything that she does likewise jojo
told et how she credits abby for putting
her on the path to stardom
i know you still have the bows that you
wore on dance moms
yes i mean you were clearly a standout
but
who would have thought
yeah no definitely not abby
she did not think yet
um i i always knew that this is what i
wanted to do
but i didn't know that like i actually
could you know like you're always like
oh yeah yeah yeah you have a dream
follow it yeah you ever believe in
yourself and you can do anything and i'm
the i'm the first one to say that i'm
i'm living proof that literally you can
do anything
but like
it's crazy
it's crazy how it happened and i
remember when i left dance moms i was so
sad like i didn't want to leave yeah and
like
i did and it worked out and i signed a
nickelodeon and now i'm on tour and i
perform and i have songs and music
videos and i have a bazillion bows and i
i like it it's amazing abby is abby and
you get yourself involved with abby
you either go to abby's studio you work
for abby abby doesn't just go pick up
people off the street like you're
working for him that's not how it works
you go to ad
you know what you're getting into
and it makes me really really really
upset that i am one of the few there's
only a few people that really truly
thank abby and are thankful and grateful
for what she's done for us because
without her
no one dance moms want to be a thing
without abby and without that
none of us would have a career
you